what we have put together is some
research project topics some
specialization tracks and some data
types that they could
um go through for these specialization
tracks so it's a matter of fact that
when you complete your training program
after that you review literature and
come up with a research question but if
you are a student and I'm not sure what
you exactly want to work with you can
explore this page that we have put
together for you I'll just share the
link in the chat all right so here we
are working on six different
specialization tracks that I wanted to
discuss today about so I showed you some
resources that you could learn from and
mutually they revolve around genomic
data analysis transcriptomics data
analysis metagenomics data analysis or
epigenomics data analysis and then we
also have courses on data science how to
use machine learning for biomedical data
analysis and then you also saw the RN
python courseworks that would be used as
a tool to analyze these different types
of data so now how we know about these
different types of data and we also know
about different types of research
specialization fields or tracks varies
different types of data
could be analyzed and we have put
together some research questions here
under each specific specialization track
the first one is infectious diseases uh
simply it could be you want to work with
covert data you have some questions put
together here under different types of
data analysis that you can pick you can
take your time to read through this page
after this session is over and let us
know what specific question or speed
interests you the most and what you want
to work on all right so back to
infectious diseases infectious diseases
are simply communicable diseases like
Ebola or covet or also we have some case
studies put together on the portal in
the example projects that you can go
through to get an idea and we have the
example projects linked up here as well
if you want to go through them and see
how you can work on these topics you you
have uh you can go through the next uh
specialization track that we have is
oncology
so here we have various types of
research questions that you can answer
under different categories of data
analysis that is possible and then the
list is very huge in number you can go
through each one of these different
topics and pick the one that interests
you the most and here we also have the
multi Onyx integration possible and also
researchers and research fellows have
been working with us on structural
biology and can informatics uh questions
too uh under the field of oncology again
we have the example projects listed out
here for you and the third
specialization track that I would like
to mention about is precision medicine
or personalized medicine we are
currently working in this domain with
transptonic data but yes also there is a
possibility that you can work with
clinical data Apple genomic data or
genomic data and under this category and
then you have agriculture as another
specialization track and then different
types of data analysis possible under
this specific track
neurosciences is another interesting
specialization track that you can pick
and we have been working extensively on
Alzheimer's disease Parkinson's disease
and also other neurodegenerated
disorders as neuro neurodegenerative
disorders are among the most researched
topics so this could be one of your
research topic that you would like to
work on as well and at the fifth
specialization track is metabolic
disorders that could be answering some
questions related to diabetes Diabetes
Type 3 is um a topic under research now
and we have few researchers and research
fellows working on Diabetes extensively
so if you want to join them and work
with them in a group it is possible and
yes definitely working on the individual
research project is a possibility
and the last specialization track that I
want to mention is space omics now this
is one of uh the most interesting fields
that is evolving and we have some
amazing space omics research projects
that I would like to definitely take you
uh through I'll just show you these
projects that you can go through and see
what is the possibility uh for you to
work on such a project again I'll repeat
the link is with you in the chat box
we'll also share it with you over an
email you can take time to go through
each one of the research questions or
topics that we have mentioned under each
type of analysis under each
specialization track and think of what
you would like to work on
and that was it I did not take up each
one of the questions because it would
have taken more time
all right now the question arises that
we have talked about different types of
data analysis and specialization tracks
but where do you run these pipelines
that I was just mentioning about I
discussed about algorithms and where do
you have all of this data analysis
possible so the answer to that is the T
bioinfo server now this is the T by info
server the Hands-On practical server
that you will be using to run all the
different types of pipelines for
different types of analysis here you
have all these analysis put together and
different sections uh you have the
transcriptomic data analysis section
then the genomic data analysis
metagenomics is here Data Mining and
then you have some phylogenic analysis
possible here on the server as well I
can see a question in the chat I just
stake up in a minute
or I can answer it now because because
it's related to the specialization track
that we just discussed so Gibson is
asking every resource specialization is
interesting what are the key criteria to
consider when deciding which research
specialization to go for
now criteria could is definitely the
first one is your interest what is your
interest what you want to work on the
second one could be where you in which
field you want to do your Majors uh if
you're a graduate student and you want
to post your Masters it would be in
which field or a PhD a PhD degree that
then in which field what are you
entrusted to learn about because it is
more important to streamline your
interest with the learning and if you
don't have an interest let's say if you
don't have an interest though that's a
very big thing but still if you don't
have an interest you can maybe pick up
one of the research questions that is
um that is more under
um I'll say curiosity of the researchers
and they're working on and you think
that you would like to add on to the
research Society by working on that
topic you can pick that but again it's
the interest that you want to work on
and where you see your uh career going
or where you where you see your videos
where you see you pursuing your Majors
into I hope that answers your questions
um
all right so now getting back to the
server where I was just showing you the
different areas of analysis and
different sections on the server so here
you have these drop downs which will
take you to some demo pipelines now
before you join a program you if you
want to see how the server works and how
these different pipelines are arranged
you can create an account on the omics
logic loan portal and that will help you
get an account on the server as well
after 24 hours and then with that
account you can access some of the demo
pipelines and see how these pipelines
basically work I will just show you one
simple pipeline today and uh it would be
a very brief a very brief pipeline just
just to Showcase how interesting it is
and uh to how interesting and easy it is
to run a pipeline on the table info
server and how interactive the results
look like so here we have a demo
Pipeline on breast cancer and uh this is
a demo pipeline where the data is
already uploaded at the back end and
being just run the pipeline and see what
the flow of the pipeline looks like and
what the results look like so I'll just
give you a background of what this
pipeline is this is a breast cancer
pipeline where you have 10 patients
um of different types of breast cancers
I'll say the first five patients are ER
positive breast cancer type patients and
the other fiber triple negative breast
cancer patients now I am interested to
look what are are the different
differential expressed genes among both
of these groups and also they know about
the Pathways in which these genes are
involved so let's begin with this
pipeline
yes so there are no prerequisites
actually to perform the data analysis
Kishore and it is not important that you
have a software background to run a
specific pipeline we'll be teaching you
everything you need to know about a
pipeline what type of data you upload
how you run the pipeline and how do you
interpret the results in the training
process when you join the research
fellowship program so you need not have
a software background to do so all right
now getting back to the pipeline I start
the pipeline and then to look for the
for the differentiating express genes I
click on the D6 uh two option and then
to look at the pathways involved I will
select enrichment analysis and glca and
simply in my pipeline now when I end my
pipeline as I told you it's a demo
pipeline we already have our results put
together and now I'll quickly open these
results to show you how easy it is to
understand what the results look like
interpret biological insights now we
have a list of results that are put
together here we can download these zip
folders and extract the fines and look
at the differentially expressed genes we
have some very interesting plots and we
also have some very interesting txt
files put together where we can see the
value of each differentially expressed
chain I'll look for each and every Gene
with regards to the samples so this is a
volcano plot that you see now these
plots are interactive you can see which
is the gene that is differentially
expressed what is the log fold change
and these terms that I am using it's not
important that you understand it now we
will we will definitely take you through
the training process where you learn
about it all and this is a heat map
which clear cut shows you what is the
expression level of different types of
genes in different samples and more the
expression level
uh more different is the expression
level highly is the differentially
expressed genes that are mentioned here
in the heat map and then you have some
interactive dashboards where you can uh
interact with these results and also
interpret what the results look like all
right so you can play around you can
increase the full change values and then
look at the differential we expressed
chains
and also if you want to look at the
pathways then you can click on the
enrichment button right here and you
will get these Pathways along with the
gene ratio and you will get to know
about what all other Pathways involved
here
so that was a very brief overview of how
you can run a pipeline and just to
Showcase you how easy it is to run this
Pipeline and then interact with these
results
all right now my last question is what
after research fellowship program so one
possibility is definitely as Roti has
shown has uh shown a publication as well
and told you it is the publication that
you can get if you dedicate good number
of fans to the research fellowship
program and work on this program so here
are some of the Publications that we
have got by research fellows and you can
go through these Publications here is
the link in the chat box and another
outcome could be publication on the
omics logic learn portal as well now
there are many students in researchers
who work on a short-term project maybe
and so what they do is they submit their
project once it's completed on the
portal and then when they extend their
Fellowship they complete their validate
their project and then take it towards
the publication so we have all our
projects here uploaded uh under the
projects tab on the omics logic learn
portal and you can go to the portal and
look at some of these project
Publications to see in which all
different specialization tracks and with
which all different data types are
research fellows have completed their
research projects